at first sight businesses in Iraq's
capital appear to abide by the curfew
that has been in place for over a month
to contain the corona virus pandemic but
knock on the closed shutters and they
will slide open just enough for visitors
to sneak in like many other businesses
this barbershop has been operating
secretly throughout much of the curfew
I'm forced to go out I have to pay rent
electricity food and medicine for my
elderly father and mother how can I pay
this is my work I don't have any other
income shop owners who defy government
orders risk temporary detention the
police turn up several times a day at
these nurseries to arrest their owners
this time they were let go after al
Jazeera arrived at the scene normally
they're taken to the police station
where they must sign a statement
promising in though further violations
and sometimes the shopkeepers say their
pressure to pay a small bribe this is
harassment they said we have orders from
the government but even if they arrest
me 100 times per day and put me in
prison I will come back here to make
money for food for my family a Ministry
of Interior spokesman denied that the
police extort business owners from money
but security forces also appear to be
using the curfew to advance their own
business interests this is one of
Baghdad's main transportation hubs and
despite the presence of police to
enforce the curfew there's a flurry of
activity we asked one taxi driver how he
manages to pass through the city's many
checkpoints he spoke on condition of
anonymity it's because I'm a member of
the security forces they facilitate the
passing for their brother who is also a
member of the security forces and life
continues normally a Ministry of
Interior spokesman told Al Jazeera that
security forces only function as drivers
to facilitate the movement of citizens
in need but many Iraqis feel that those
in power are taking advantage while
ordinary citizens are struggling to get
by
the curfew in Baghdad was partially
lifted on Tuesday meaning that some
businesses can once again operate freely
without the risk of penalties but
there's also concerned that reopening
could lead to a spike in covert 19 in
sections semana 14 al Jazeera Baghdad